من سنين و احنا لما حدا بيحكي او بده يحكي
عن سكان العالم وعن عددهم او يعبر مثلا عن
همم او مثلا عن التدوير ما بين سكان
العالم على شيء كان دائما بيحكي سبعه
مليارات نسمه من اليوم هذا التعبير لازم
نغيره فسبعه مليار صاروا ثمانيه مليار
والامم المتحده اعلنت انه تقديراتها تحققت
واليوم يعني 15 نوفمبر 2022 تجاوزه سكان
العالم حاجز الثماني مليارات نسمه بحسب
بيان الامم المتحده نمو سكان العالم من
سبعه مليار الى ثمانيه مليار استغرق حوالي
12 سنه اسباب زياده بحسب الامم المتحده هي
تحسن في الخدمات الصحيه والاجتماعيه
والتغذيه والتنميه الاقتصاديه وغيرها يعني
المفروض انه هذا كلام جميل يعني خبر صار
على كل حال انطونيش الامين العام للامم
المتحده كانت تعليقه على الخبر
باحتفالي نوعا ما انه هذه عتبه يتجاوزها
العالم وهي فرصه للاحتفال بالتنوع والتطور
ومراعاه المسؤوليه المشتركه للبشريه اتجاه
الكوكب
طبعا خبر وصوصه كان العالم من الثماني
مليارات نسمه من العناوين الاولى حول
العالم على فكره طبعا وحتى صارت ترند في
معظم الدول وعلى مختلف المنصات وفي الوقت
اللي في ناس في عام لاحتفالات وبتهل
بوصولنا لثمانيه مليارات نسمه في ناس
ثانيه منهاره وشايفه انه يا جماعه الكوكب
ما كان حملنا احنا واحنا سبعه مليار فما
بالكم الان واحنا ثمانيه مليار وبتسائل
طبعا او بتسالوا هؤلاء الناس عن موارد
الكوكب هل هي قادره اصلا علينا كلنا وفي
ناس كثير ثاني في النصف مش عارفين شو لازم
يكون موقفها لازم يحتفلوا وينبسطوا واللي
يزعلوا يلطمه على كل حال خلينا نحاول نوصل
لحل مع ضيفنا اللي بنرحب فيه الان هو معنا
عبر الهاتف الدكتور حسين محادين استاذ علم
الاجتماع وعميت كليه العلوم الاجتماعيه في
جامعه مؤته سابقا
فيك دكتور حسين معنا همم في تفاعل لكم
اهلا مساء الخير لك جميعا
طيب دكتور احنا شو المفروض نعمل مفروض
ناخذ هذا الخبر وننبسط فيه نصرنا ثمانيه
مليارات نسمه واللي عن جد الناس اللي
بيلطموا وقاعدين بيقولوا انه هاي مصيبه
علينا هم اللي صح
خلينا نحكي الان مباركه
الامم المتحده لهذا الموضوع
والبعض الاخر الذي يفكر بعقليه متقدم
واستشافيه يقول ان همم
يولد معه تحديات جديده في الحياه ابدا من
المناخ
وتاثيراته المختلفه
نورا بالمعارك والصدامات والحروب هنا
وهناك وليس انتهاء في الزلازل والبراكين
التي من شانها ان تخلص من اعداد
الناس على وجه هذه الكره لكن نقول ايضا من
ناحيه علميه ان هناك علاقه طرديه اي زياده
مع زياده كلما زاد هذا السكان كلما زاد
الضغط على المناخ وادره في الحياه اليوميه
سواء على الارض او في الفضاء
يعني هو منطقي لانه راح يزيد طلبنا على
الوقود واللي هو بدوره بيؤدي للاحتباس
الحراري بتغيير المناخي وما الى ذلك يمكن
السؤال الاكبر او هؤلاء الناس اللي حاسين
انه لازم يلطمه همم هم همم قلقانين بشان
الموارد مش بس موارد الطاقه الاكل همم حتى
المكان هل يسعنا اذا كانت الزياده هاي راح
تستمر هل هناك مشكله في موارد الارض هل هي
محدوده وما راح تكفينا اذا ضلينا نزيد بها
الوتيره ولا هذا موضوع خلينا نتركه جماعه
نظريه المؤامره اللي همم اللي هنا بيامنوا
بهذا الموضوع لانه في ناس بيقولوا لا ما
له دخل موضوع الموارد همم يعني يكفي ويزيد
وتوزيعه على الارض وتعامل مع الموارد
الطبيعيه والغذائيه بالمجمل لكن ايضا هناك
اختلال في البناء ال-
هذه الارض فالدول التي همم هي الاغنى هي
التي تساهم في همم اذا زياده الضغوط على
حياه الناس من جهه وهناك ايضا تحدي الغذاء
نفسه
منذ 60 نيئه الماضي كان يتحدث عن زياده
السكان زياده طرديه متسارعه والموارد
المتاحه محدوده نحن نقول ان الاستثمار
الامثل الموارد التقليل من عوامل اضعاف
واجهات الارض
وتطور العلمي وخصوصا في حقول الزراعه
والغذاء ولا ننساه
مقتنيات البحر بكل عناوين كله عوامل
مشانها ان توفر فرصه معقوله الى الحياه
لكن ايضا هناك تيار مغاير يرى ان العالم
يجب ان يقف بحدود 500 مليارات والخمسه
الذهبيات كما يصفها هذه الايام
ان هناك ثلاثه مليار الا شويه قبل اليوم
يشكلون عبئا على مصادر الموارد وامكانيه
العيش همم اعتقد ان هذا الموضوع بيثير همم
حتى سؤال همم فيما يتعلق بالاخلاق يعني
نوعا ما او سؤال فلسفي انه طيب هؤلاء من
انا ممكن او حضرتك او اي شخص احنا بنحبه
وبنعرفه ممكن يعني يعتبر عبء فايش نصف
سكان الارض يجب التخلص منها يعني
ههه هذول الناس الذين يريدون نظريه
الانتخابات
متقدم وان الضعفاء ليس لهم حق الحياه
النظريه قديمه ولا يمكن ان يمكن ان هناك
من همم ما زال معتقدا باهميه رغم القيمه
الاخلاقيه التي ذكرناها وقيمه الانسان
الذي كرمه الله عز وجل لامار الحياه
واعمار الارض المجمل هناك سيارات شكريه
متعدده لكن الواقع الاوضح هو اننا اليوم
امام رقم ثمانيه مليار انسان على هذا
الكوكب والبعض الاخر ايضا يرى ان هذه
الارض لم تعد تتسع هذه الاعداد العائلي
فيفكر في الذهبي الى الفضاء وغيره من
العلوم ولنا اختبار مثلا قوي اثناء ازمه
الكرونه فيما همم ترتب على كنافات
والامراض وانت شالهما على هذه الشيء
ولا نلطم ولا نهاجر على الفضاء يعني اذا
هيك ههه
شكرا
اجتماعيه في جامعه مؤته السابقه
[موسيقى]